مع الشعب الفلسطيني
حشدوا بعد اغتيال هذا
الصحفي الذي كان حقًا
المثال المعروف هذه هي القوى
جيوش دولة إسرائيل
قتل عمدا اليوم
الحياة الفلسطينية
حسنًا ، إنها اغتيالات
المقاوم وأوصاف اثنين
بيوت ممنوع العيش فيها
عادة مثل ومثل أي شخص آخر
الناس وهكذا هو بالتأكيد
ضرورية للتعبئة من أجلهم
الجانب كلما تعرضوا للهجوم
حقًا إنه أمر شائن حقًا
القرص كما لو كانوا
الفلسطينيين الذين استفزوا حين
لا لا جذر كل ما يحدث
نحن سوف
إنه استعمار إنه فصل عنصري
الإسرائيلي من المشين أن المدرسة
هي وسائل الإعلام هي الاسم المستعار لرجل العمل
آرثر ماير
لا يختلف عن الأول بينهما
في انتظارهم إطلاق النار على قائد السفينة
أنا الأول بعد افتتاح مارك
منتجات رجالي
لقد سرقت المدينة هناك هذه المرة
جلبت إلى التربة من قبل آتي يدك
معهم
فرنسي
الشخص كاذب
قبل
[موسيقى]